did you know that the current water
hashiragu tomioka actually wants tanjiro
to take his position as the water
hashira that's because giu thinks of
himself as a fake he sees himself as an
imposter who isn't worthy of being
ahashira giyu has a bad case of imposter
syndrome he feels that he never truly
passed his selection exam because he got
injured during his first fight against
the demon and then his life had to be
saved by sabito sabito eventually
sacrificed his life to save the lives of
multiple people and thanks to this
sacrifice giyu survived and passed the
exam guiyu feels survivor's guilt and he
doesn't think that someone who didn't
even defeat a single demon during his
final selection can call himself a
hashira if you want to know more about
guiyu's past and if you want a breakdown
of all his powers and abilities check
out my full video link in the
description and in the pin comment